[Musique]
à 21 ans hugo et le créateur de ce décor
féerique un grand enfant qui se fait à
chaque noël depuis quatre ans un cadeau
de plusieurs milliers d'euros
tout m'a récompensé lors voir le public
les enfants émerveillés ils parlent
initiés qui sont émerveillés devant le
décor
ils sont heureux les enfants ont jusqu'à
demain pour écrire gratuitement au père
noël
enfin jeudi les enfants nous on peut lui
écrire à tout âge à la preuve avec cette
lettre envoyée par deux dames qui se
présente comme ayant 73 et 74 ans et qui
réclame cette année au pied du sapin je
cite un compagnon pas trop vieux avec un
compte en banque bien fourni
le succès est tellement évêques
maintenant vos autographes se vendre sur
ebay françois bon pas une fortune donc
combien band 3 0 15 15
je m'enferme 15 + 15 mons 14,99 c'est
pas des manchots à donnery 267 jours de
travail depuis le début de l'épidémie
pas un seul jour de repos et la bonne
humeur chevillée au corps comment
voulez-vous interagir avec un patient en
ressemblant à un martien où un
astronaute
c'est pour ça que j'ai eu cette idée d'
accrocher nos portraits mais la photo de
brad pitt et les patients me disent ah
vous êtes plus mauvaises habitudes
alors qu'est ce que tu en penses tu
alors moi je suis pas trop robe courte
passe à tout va bien oui c'est joli mais
bon ça casse pas 3 camaret de pâtes quoi
bon sens du terme
est-ce que vous n'êtes ni valérie sous
la couette actuellement est ce que vous
êtes sous une boule de neige qui serait
tombé ou étouffés parce qu'on vous
attend sur effectivement les gestes
barrière vérifier qu'il n'y ait personne
à moins de 47 km c'est les nouvelles
mesures vous le savez l'ancien premier
ministre a été plutôt discret à anvers
les caméras il se tenait souvent à
l'écart dans ce déplacement laissant le
ministre de la santé olivier verront
s'entretenir avec les personnels de
santé mais également avec les personnes
qui venaient se faire téter a pas de
politique mais un petit cocorico
plusieurs français interpellés dans la
nuit samedi
mais oui on sait faire c'était dans les
ardennes belges à la police a été
appelée pour un tapage nocturne mais les
policiers ont surpris et interpellé 56
fêtards certains dans le plus simple
appareil
les personnes interpellées ou est coupée
ont écopé d'une amende de 250 euros et
selon le journal de la meuse
il s'agissait d'une soirée échangiste
alors évidemment les gestes barrières
étaient peu respectée si vous voulez et
allocation fête anniversaire c'est ton
anniversaire
on va rencontrer des amis pratiquement
un an que nos vies se résume à dormir et
travailler on a bien droit de se
détendre et de faire un peu la fête
c'est humain et je dirais même plus
vitales et je vois que enfin moi j'aime
beaucoup voyagé j'aimerais l'attirer
dans
dans mes voyages alors voila j'aimerais
l'entraîner dans mes voyages parce
qu'elle attire et c'est déjà fait chaque
fois que je dis quelque part il faut
renforcer notre fusent contre la
polygamie il ya toujours des gens pour
dire ah là là mais voulait interdire
l'infidélité vous à les interdire les
troupes vous à les interdire les plans à
trois je veux rassurer tout le monde on
va pas interdire les plans à trois va
pas interdire l'infidélité on va pas
interdire le polyamour et ben il se
trouve que nous sommes trois dans studio
nous sommes très rassuré quand je pense
qu'à une certaine époque on avait des
ddd andré malraux georges pompidou des
petites raymond barre jusqu'à rossi
alors à temps mais je suis désolé mais
jusqu à l'écrit notre jeu vient
d'annoncer quand il était aux fraises se
disait le général de gaulle non pas dans
le gène armée de coup droit sans qu'on
le cherche en vain et pour cause le
point g n'existe pas mais cette fois
c'est que cette histoire nous expliquer
non mais oui mais il y avait un tas de
noms ça va c'est chaud à chaud j'ai des
goûts de taula dans leur est à l'arrêt
du cul qui te fait chez nous allez et
pourquoi l'appareil et tiramisu parce
que ma mère travaille toute la semaine
et quand le week-end comme des personnes
normaux qui travaillent le dimanche
elle fait un tirage ce que tu manges tu
le dis ah ouais je suis mal je pense que
tu es un pâtissier professionnels
j'ai une tête de pâtissier moi je n'ai
même pas faire des pâtés un steak et
chats met de la vie dans son creux mais
ce qui il faut pas qu'elle se rate sur
l'équilibré et le mariage des saveurs et
j'espère qu'elle va pas se faire bouffer
par le stress du concours aïe aïe aïe
aïe aïe super mamie une soirée animée
par fabienne fabienne qui a vraiment le
don de mettre l'ambiance en présentant
les participantes 82 ans de bonheur et
d'optimisme malgré que la vie n'a pas
été toujours facile et c'est vous avez
gardé cette joie de vivre
[Musique]
rien maringa je suis énervé contre euro
mais pourquoi tusk
pourquoi j'arrive arrière dans la nuit
même arrive enfin
mais non mais je suis pas fier bien ya
un concours mais tu rigoles ou quoi
je ne dis pas ça rend compte de ce que
tu as fait jusqu'à maintenant cette
élection nous a offert un impressionnant
remake de moulin rouge
[Musique]
nicole kidman n'a qu'à bien se tenir
enfin quand vous dansez vous ai pas les
mêmes risques quand vous que quand vous
jouez au coq encore vous bédave excusez
moi quand vous quoi bédave sétois bel
avait espéré téléspectateurs les plus
jeunes comprendront sans vouloir vous en
france ça veut dire ça veut dire je vous
fais ça veut dire quoi nous fait une
caméra de surveillance films dépassant
glissé sur un trottoir verglacée à kiev
en ukraine
si la vidéo est virale c'est aux dépens
de cette passante à chaque pas c'est la
chute
et rien n'y fait ni la main tendue d'un
bon samaritain
ni le soutien d'un mur peut-être qu'à
quatre pattes
non c'est retour à la case départ
finalement elle abandonne et disparaît
bien maladroitement du champ de vision